sometimes we inherit a poorly documented
Google Cloud project or our own project
might have grown over time and become
messy I know that has happened to me
more than a few times
wouldn't it be great if we could just
get a map of everything in the project
we can open the cloud console click the
hamburger menu pick I am an admin and
then click asset inventory you can use
this tool to see Cloud run Services
Cloud functions service accounts
databases storage buckets virtual
machines and pretty much anything else
that can be part of a project you can
also get a bird's eye view of what
account can do what in the project
I think it's a good idea to periodically
audit projects that host production
applications that way you can catch and
lock down unneeded permissions and
remove resources that were created by
mistake now go and take control of your
projects with the asset inventory tool